Speaker 1: You know, ever since we started hearing
about the labor shortage situation here in the
U.S., there's been so much blame to go around.
Some people like to blame lazy millennials. Other
people like to blame the Joe Biden administration.
Other people like to blame poor people who are
just unwilling to go get a job. And you know,
there's been this idea that because of the
boosted unemployment benefits, that meant that
many people were just one willing to get a job.
They wanted to just stay home and live off of
government resources. The same was said about
the stimulus checks with the idea that, OK, well,
if you get a thousand dollars here and there,
you don't really need to work, which is kind of
silly, really, because obviously a thousand bucks
or 100 bucks, $4800, that's not going to be enough
to cover your long term basic needs. And indeed,
the labor shortage does persist. The number of job
openings was at an all time high. As of October,
at more than 11 million openings and companies
are struggling still to hire enough workers to
meet the demand. But the truth is that the labor
shortage is caused by a multitude of factors,
and chief among them have to do with baby
boomers retiring early and a reduction in
worker visas that have been granted over the
course of the pandemic. Overall, I was able to
come up with eight reasons in total for the labor
shortage situation, so I wanted to run through
them all with you here. So number one, and
these are in no particular order people are
retiring. Early estimates suggest that the U.S.
has about two million more retirees right now than
we otherwise would have expected if we had not
had the pandemic. And this makes sense because
let's say you were 62 years old when the pandemic
started and you planned on retiring at age 65.
Well, by now you're about sixty three and a half
going on 64. Do you really want to go back to
work for another year or so, especially when you
already are semi-retired, as it is? Probably not,
especially given the fact that the stock market
has boomed over the past couple of years so
people's retirement accounts are higher than they
expected them to be. Also, real estate values have
gone up significantly, so people assuming they
own their house and assuming they have a 401k
or an IRA, they've seen a sizable growth in
their wealth over the past couple of years,
making it so they may not have to keep working.
They might as well just retire early. Number two
has to do with immigration. The U.S. government
has issued about 1.2 million fewer visas to
adult immigrants, refugees and temporary foreign
workers. And I think this is intuitive given that
restrictions on travel were in existence,
especially during the early phase of the
pandemic. Many of these restrictions still exist
today. There's a chance also that you know,
things can turn around because now the Department
of Homeland Security has announced that the Biden
administration is going to be adding 20000 new
slots to a seasonal guest worker program for
the winter season. But it makes sense that given
there's a pandemic raging throughout the world,
people just don't want to be traveling
from country to country. Number three,
there's a skills mismatch of 48 percent of workers
said that they were frustrated with the surge,
and 46 percent said that they can only find
Low-paying roles just because a job is available.
That doesn't mean that people necessarily want
to take that job. It doesn't necessarily mean
that it's a good paying job. And we know that some
people were able to take advantage of their time
off during the pandemic, and many people learn new
skills. They did online classes, et cetera. And so
their market value has improved. But if they don't
find a job that matches their skill improvement,
maybe they're just going to decide to hold out.
No, for commuting people many times just don't
want to go back to commuting. Obviously, during
the beginning phase of the pandemic, many workers
moved out of the areas that would be hiring by
now, like they moved from cities to rural areas,
and they just have decided they don't want to
commute anymore. That's been my experience. Like,
I like working from home. It wouldn't be a total
deal breaker for me if I had to start going back
into an office every day, but I'd prefer
to just keep working from home. Obviously,
commuting can be very, very stressful, especially
if you have a long commute, like if you're driving
an hour to and from work every day. I mean, that's
just crazy. If you don't have to do it anymore,
why would you want to? So commuting obviously
is a big factor. Number five, child care.
Most schools are open at this point, but there
can be cancelations based on COVID cases at the
drop of a hat. Maybe the school year gets halted
early. Obviously, we're seeing some closures now
with Macron. So sometimes parents who may be
working part time while the kids are at school,
they can't do that anymore because they have
to be home to take care of the child. Or at
least they have to keep that as an option in case
school does get shut down. Number six is protests
over vaccine mandates. There are some people
who are just not going to get the vaccine no
matter what. It doesn't matter if you offer
them a carrot or a stick. And so obviously,
if they refuse to get the vaccine, there are
so many jobs that they're no longer eligible
for. They can't work for a government agency
or they can't be a government contractor.
They can't work for a company with more than
50 employees. They can't work in certain cities
in the country. So obviously that lowers their
possibilities when it comes to the job market,
and that's also contributing in part to the labor
shortage. Number seven Fear of the virus cases
are obviously surging out of control right
now. The al-Muqrin variant is super. Tejas,
and so there are people who are maybe older
or immunosuppressed, and they feel as though,
you know, I want to get a job, but I don't want to
put my life at risk by doing so. And number eight,
the great resignation. This is a term coined
by organizational psychologist Anthony Klotz,
who theorizes that people, especially
pre-pandemic, they would tie in their identity
with their work. And now with people taking
some time off and really being confronted with
their mortality because the amount of people
who have died over the past couple of years,
it's caused a shift in their perspective and they
no longer wrap up their identity with what they do
as a job. And I think that, you know, maybe the
great resignation talking point is a little bit
overblown because after all, people need to work
to survive. Most people do anyway. But you know,
there could be some people who decide, I'm not
going to work 40 to 50 hours a week anymore. I'm
going to work part time. Or maybe I'll take a few
more years off and resume working later. Maybe I
want to decide that I'm going to do something
else with my life. So it's definitely a mix of
factors. Some of these things you're going to
be able to improve over time, other things you
may not be able to like, for example, the Baby
Boomers retiring early. Are you really going to
be able to bring them back into the job market?
Probably not. They're probably retired and not
going to be entering the job force again, at least
not in mass. But then there's other factors that
will improve as the state of coronavirus in this
country improves. As we finally see cases go
down and we finally start to see deaths go down
whenever that may be, the economy will follow.
We've been saying this for two years now that you
have to deal with the virus before you can deal
with the economy. And we'll hope that this all
sort of sorts itself out. But that's the sort of
update now having to do with the labor shortage
and many of the reasons why it's happening.